[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] I
mean, we live as a whole as a single family in this
village. He deserves thanks, which was the true thinker
and builder
of this village, our
honorable brother. We call this tile perforated or perforated. Of course, this tile is
because for me, for example, it
makes it possible for me to distinguish my entry from my room when it is useful
in this way.  We
enter like this and of course we go towards the kitchen to the bathroom.
[Music] My
father takes us to play against the halaytat, meaning the swings.
Praise be to God, Lord of the worlds. My father
teaches us how to walk while here. This is the symbol of the house, in your opinion, which
I would like to teach you about writing. It is very
useful for the blind. This box flashes
to the letter it is in.  This, for example, means the
Alif, and this, for example, the B, means there are six points inside each square.
[Music]
I was injured in 2016, including only my eyes. The injury was the result of a missile from a Syrian warplane. We succeeded in this stage, and with us
here I was injured in a war, and I suffered from going to the
hospital, meaning the left eye was damaged.
Artificial crystal, the eye, Yemen, a fragment in which
the retina was removed, and I lost my sight completely from 2019 to 2022,
until our situation stabilized in Al Noor Village for the Blind. Of
course, the blind person is unable to work
and unfortunately does not have job opportunities. We
always hope for more support from job opportunities
that help the blind person to fulfill his needs.
His duty towards his family and towards his community
[music]